todos los votos ya han sido contados las
actas de perú arrojan que el candidato
izquierdista a la presidencia del país
pedro castillo tiene el 51% de los votos
sólo cuarenta y cuatro mil cincuenta y
ocho papeletas más que su rival la
conservadora keiko fujimori sin embargo
todavía no hay un ganador oficial a la
espera de que el jurado nacional
electoral resuelva las impugnaciones
interpuestas por fujimori quien sostiene
que la estrecha victoria de castillo se
debe al fraude electoral
la tensión aumenta en las calles de perú
donde las manifestaciones de bando y
bando se suceden castillo llamó a sus
seguidores a seguir movilizándose de
manera pacífica reiteramos que no vamos
a tener no vamos nos van a encontrar
nadie ninguna agresión
pero tampoco vamos a permitir que se
siga discriminando a un pueblo oprimido
por más años
democráticamente las cosas se han puesto
en la mesa y democráticamente tiene que
darse una salida
la decisión final del jurado electoral
podría tardar días en llegar y las
autoridades peruanas tratan de hacer
respetar las reglas electorales del país
rechazamos todo discurso o acto que
suponga el desconocimiento de los
resultados electorales que habrá de
anunciar oficial y oportunamente la
autoridad electoral y de cualquier
intento de afectar el orden
constitucional mientras tanto los
peruanos siguen sin saber quién ocupará
la presidencia más de una semana después
de acudir a las urnas